imagine a world where anything you can
think of can become a reality
a watermelon pie we got it a cactus
ghost got it hunter s thompson as a
president we got that too the last week
i've been obsessed with an ai image
generator called mid journey you put in
a prompt like the perfect cloud and it
spits out some results
sometimes they're terrible sometimes
they're bizarrely terrifying but just as
many times they're incredible here's a
movie camera by pablo picasso infinite
cabbage a bathroom designed by m.c
escher a person made entirely out of
cheese deluxe beans a strip mall painted
by monet dune directed by wes anderson a
bubble gum farm family dinner painted by
david lynch chicken nuggets at a
michelin star restaurant cotton candy
grapes twin peaks drawn by a child
potted tongue plant pills by gucci i've
spent hours now surfing through what is
essentially humanity's collective
imagination remixed by my own random
ideas and a powerful ai it's addicting
and fascinating every image is a gamble
you don't know if it's going to spit out
something amazing or just a pile of
trash
what about a pile of trash by van gogh
but it's as terrifying as it is
fascinating as this technology improves
which it is already dali 2 google's own
image generation ai that isn't available
for the public yet is already much
stronger than mid journey which i've
been using what will it mean for art
images imagination what is a world where
anything we can imagine can become a
reality
how does encountering this world make
you feel
what if we put everything on a bagel
everything
all my hopes and dreams my
old report cards
every breed of dog every last personal
ad on craigslist
sesame
poppy seed
salt
there's a new feeling i've started
encountering in recent years it's hard
to describe it's kind of uncomfortable
fractal overwhelming disorienting but at
the same time enticing and kind of
awe-inspiring for a while i didn't know
where this feeling was coming from what
was causing it or how many other people
might be feeling what i was feeling but
then in 2021 i started noticing a few
artists depicting the feeling that i was
having bo burnham was the first to put
his finger on it with his comedy special
inside
[Music]
that funny feeling
[Music]
but another recent work which captures
the feeling and an even more fundamental
way is the hyper-modern maximalist
everything everywhere all at once
[Applause]
you underestimate how the smallest
decision can compound into significant
differences over a lifetime
every tiny decision creates another
branching universe another
were you not paying attention before
it's easy to get bogged down in the
technical elements of multiverses and
how they work either as a storytelling
device or as an actual theory for our
own cosmos but what i'm most interested
in about the multiverse as it's used in
everything everywhere all at once is as
a metaphor for our own world and our own
personal experience especially as a
metaphor for the experience of
[Music]
i love the internet i've always loved
learning about new and novel things and
have had an insatiable curiosity and for
someone who could spend all their time
exploring what's out there if they
didn't have to do other things like eat
pay rent and socialize the internet has
been an endless garden of delight and
possibility the internet has an
inexhaustible variety of cool stuff and
tons of fascinating people and ideas to
discover the internet is why i get to do
something like this as a job but it's a
double-edged sword i thought i was
disconnected
why was i still there your mind is like
a clay pot holding water every jump
opens another crack causing things to
leak through even when pointed at
seemingly productive learning and not
just mindless entertainment when given
the option to fulfill endless curiosity
there comes a tipping point a crossing
of the bell curve sucked
into
a bagel here's the thing
we don't need an actual multiverse to
put cracks in the clay pot of our mind
when we already have devices for
careening through the endless
imaginations of the multitudes when we
exist in an environment where you can
encounter the personal stories and
experiences from people on every
continent all who are living their own
unique life in just a few minutes all
from the comfort of your own toilet when
more interesting ideas concepts people
and places can fly by in the space of
one 30-minute tick-tock binge than some
of our ancestors experienced in the
entirety of their localized illiterate
lives
the internet for those who are inspired
to spend a lot of time on it and use it
in a certain way for those who envelop
themselves in its self-referential world
of constantly evolving novelty and
imagery will inevitably have a profound
effect on the way you see the world what
is the result of this headlong dive
through novel ideas and imagery
[Music]
many astronauts upon seeing the earth
for the first time from space spinning
by below them report something that has
been dubbed
the overview effect when they see the
world they've always known from such a
radically different viewpoint flying by
in its entirety in the space of 90
minutes hundreds or thousands of times
it can cause a significant paradigm
shift in how they view life and the
world i don't think the effect of being
very online is the same thing as the
overview effect that astronauts
experience but i think there's a lighter
weight analogous effect that can happen
from consuming the amount of information
that many of us now do using the
internet
seeing so much of the world so quickly
can trigger a sort of psychological
paradigm shift the shift isn't coming
from being exposed to a single new idea
or perspective that forces you to
reassess your own the shift comes from
the sheer amount of perspectives and
ideas that we can now be exposed to
online
the shift from being online all the time
contains some positives but it can also
leave you stuck in a state of overwhelm
constantly considering alternative life
paths constantly comparing your own
experience to the experience of others
unable to hold a consistent view of
what's real or what is important for
most people i think the digital overview
effect is a gradual and pervasive
accumulation slowly building up as we
swim through a world of thoughts ideas
concepts and emotions all projected at
us through images text and video one
after another in an endless parade each
new idea can pull you in a different
direction and there's a certain point if
you go far enough and fast enough where
everything the infinite possibility of
life starts to blur by and look and feel
like nothing and at that point the
entire thing collapses on itself what
is the truth
nothing
matters
[Music]
for me everything everywhere all at once
is one of the first true post-internet
films it's not just about the internet
it doesn't just comment on the internet
but fully embraces it in all of its
absurdist chaotic glory the maximalist
excess and complete tonal whiplash from
one moment to the next captures the
unhinged unfiltered anarchy of using the
internet in a way that nothing else i've
ever consumed has
she appears to be in a universe where
everyone has
hot dogs instead of fingers this is a
movie for people who have found
themselves blinking asleep out of their
eyes with 50 tabs open at 2am which i
suspect is many more of us than we'd
openly care to admit
in an interview with slash film daniel
shinart one of the movie's directors
said we've talked a lot about what it's
like to have grown up on the internet
and how that exacerbated the typical
generational divide and what it feels
like for everyone no matter how old you
are to live right now with the internet
so that's one of the key metaphors was
just like we wanted the maximalism of
the movie to connect with what it's like
to scroll through an infinite amount of
stuff which is something we're all doing
too much
most media that tries to comment on the
internet comments on the content of the
internet or one small aspect of it that
it wants to critique
but it doesn't comment on the message
that comes from the medium of the
internet the feeling of the experience
of the internet the way the most absurd
or inane things you've ever seen coexist
in the immediate context of tragedy and
posts from your friends and family
everything everywhere all at once does
comment on this experience it's silly
and stupid and chaotic because well
welcome to the internet have a look
around anything that brain of yours can
think of can be found jobu tupaki is a
child of the internet raised in and by
the chaos of the multiverse cast
unknowingly by her parents without
training wheels into the void she
doesn't have the skills to cope with
that experience and neither do many of
the real teenagers who are growing up on
the internet now evelyn her mother first
tries to resist this experience and then
tries to understand but eventually
realizes that she too is not equipped to
handle the onslaught of experiencing the
internet head-on
how do we handle this situation how do
we stare head-on to the darkness of the
bagel and survive maybe you haven't
experienced what i'm talking about maybe
you don't know what i mean maybe you've
ventured into this brave new world and
have come out relatively unscathed but
even if you haven't been negatively
affected by it i would argue that you
probably are impacted by it in some way
our world is being shaped right now by
people who have gone in and haven't come
out unscathed and while my parents
generation and my generation still got
to grow up with the internet as a thing
that we go to and then can go away from
the current generation is living with it
as an omnipresent extension of
themselves they're growing up in a
technological world increasingly
dominated by the internet their
education their social lives and their
careers are intertwined with this
experience and it increasingly takes a
particularly bold and defined individual
to even take a step back from this world
and it's not slowing down while the
adults in power are just now noticing
the issues that reared their heads
almost a decade ago the next decade
holds a whole new set of wonders and
terrors that we're waiting to embrace
with open arms it might sound from all
of this like i feel like it's a hopeless
situation but i don't feel hopeless and
i don't think everything everywhere all
at once does either the film ultimately
affirms a quiet acceptance of a life
that openly acknowledges the infinite
chaos and possibility swirling around us
vying for our attention but chooses to
quietly ignore it in order to value
what's immediately in front of you no
matter what
i still want to be here with you and i
think one of the points that the movie
tries to make is that in order to engage
with the multiverse of the internet in a
healthier way you have to understand
what doesn't matter to you
because attention is the economy of the
internet and we pay attention to things
we see as important so the entire engine
of the internet is built to convince you
that everything matters all at once all
the time
but in the real world in the world
you're living in you can only pay
attention to a few things in one place
at a time
you're just gonna ignore everything else
and in order to pay attention to the few
things that do matter you have to look
at a world of infinite possibility out
there and boldly proclaim that it
doesn't matter and that's not to say
that nothing on the internet or that you
find on the internet matters but the
point is it can't all matter equally to
you if you try to act like it all
matters equally to you you'll end up
feeling like none of it matters there's
a quote from marshall mcluhan that gives
me hope when i'm thinking about these
kinds of issues and so i'll leave you
with that there is no inevitability so
long as there is a willingness to
contemplate what is happening
imagine a world in the multiverse where
nobody shaved it probably wouldn't look
like that med journey image but i might
find it nice i've never really enjoyed
shaving and a big part of that is
because i've never found a razor that
meets all of the specific wants that i
have i've never liked how the standard
cartridge razors that you get from most
of these subscription services generate
a lot of plastic waste i mean imagine
what the world is going to look like
when it eventually fills up with plastic
razors and you have to keep paying for
it which gets expensive i've always had
issues with electric razors the
alternative to those options that i've
tried to use in the past are these
things safety razors in theory they're
pretty ideal but in practice they're
pretty hard to use and contrary to their
name they don't feel very safe it's
pretty easy to like get the angle wrong
or nick yourself or something like that
that's where the sponsor for this video
comes in this is the henson shaving
al-13 this thing is honestly like the
perfected version of one of these it has
all the upsides and none of the
downsides i had a very easy time shaving
with this it felt good and i got a clean
shave with no issues no razor burn for
what i want from a razor this checks all
the boxes it does a good shave it's
sustainable you just replace the blades
which are recyclable there's no plastic
in this thing it really doesn't get
clogged which is amazing and the way the
razor itself is designed to hold the
blade makes for a more precise shave but
the high quality design and material
means that this razor should also last
you basically your entire life it might
feel like you're paying a little bit
more money up front but over time you're
saving a lot of money going this route
we're talking three to five dollars per
year for the replacement blades
depending on how much you shave and you
don't even have to buy those from henson
shaving they're not a proprietary blade
you can just use any standard double
edge razor blade when you buy this thing
a pack of 100 blades are on me just add
100 blades to the checkout use code
thomasflight and those blades will be
free go to the link in the description
or on the screen and use code
thomasflight to pick up your henson
shaving al13 thanks again to
hensonshaving for sponsoring this video
[Music]